Why wasn't the lost technique of the individual
put into action in the last war
?
Your [
Music] It
's probably something similar.
Interesting
[Music]
In the area,
various loads such as gravity, atmospheric pressure, and temperature rise.
How long can I withstand this kind of human being?
If I curse a mere beautiful girl for this kind of treatment,
[Applause] If I
just push forward from the outside, I'll be crushed from the moment I enter.
[Music]
Perhaps the prefecture's original report will descend into another dimension.  It's
heavier than it looks.
If that's true, then let's outdo it with speed. Maybe I'll
use stepping or catch.
If
I die, I'll drop a small flower and a
round piece of candy.  Please be prepared.
Goodbye, everyone. Goodbye.
Weak power.
Were you the type of person that when you concentrate on one thing, you neglect the other?
Turning bad news. I almost
self-destructed here as a result of the volume. It's
almost like a foothold in the air that you can't see.
Deploy your thoughts in the air,
Olivia. It's
clever, but if your patterns are limited, you
should just aim for the landing. I caught
this line.
[Music]